okay why don't we get started here
uh the first one is the liquor
the liquor bill relative delinquent
payment of accounts by on-premise and
off-premise licensees
um so unfortunately we should have taken
this up last week but I
failed to put it down I failed to do it
and um so now we need to discuss it uh
okay
Yeah so basically it raises the the
dollar amount
uh the minimum dollar amount the law has
been in on the books for a very very
long time
and so raising it is pretty
nominal
um the commission has no problems with
with the higher dollar amount
I mean uh
give me that it is and it is an
interesting law it's in the idea that uh
because uh the commission requires when
you file when the beer distributors
finally it has to uh report the sales of
beer and then and the and the collection
of the tax and so theoretically the your
distributor has to pay the tax to
commission and so uh the beer
distributors want to make sure that
they've actually been paid themselves
yeah and uh so we do have this law on
the books
uh
but so but the dollar amount is de
minimis and some people who knows what
the reason why they haven't paid that
whatever that small amount of money so
the idea that that they have to be put
on the bad boy list and
uh seems uh a little ridiculous for just
100 bucks so
okay
so who's here
oh my God because I know too sick is off
foreign
Bill signing
Lily you're here
Anita's here and
Jason's here okay
so uh anybody want to make the motion
this is Executives next week
this bill this is just the subcommittee
okay so I'll I'll make the motion of uh
to pass okay
okay uh any discussion on the motion
about to pass
seeing none all those in favor raise
your hand one two three
no
okay
all right
or zip
Marvel how I do that okay
okay so this is the uh Secretary of
State's uh housekeeping measure
let's see what if we have for the
Secretary of State's office
um and it's a myriad of different little
issues um
nothing
nothing is there any does anybody have
any questions in anything
okay so representative Ammon Cole
Thaxton hunt McAleer Herbert infilio
okay
anybody have any
questions or concerns seem like a pretty
and we're creating a whole new
Corporation type PBC
is that a new type or we
good morning everyone
um Yes No actually that's we currently
have in New Hampshire uh public benefit
corporations however when someone
designates themself as one they don't it
does not indicate it in their title they
still list themselves as an ink or
Corporal limited someone has to look it
up to see so yeah so in Most states um
they allow them to to use that that
ending PBB like LLC but yeah that
basically tell us the public that they
are a public benefit Corporation
um we have out-of-state companies that
register here that have that designation
and we can't allow them to register
under that name because we don't
recognize it in our statute so this
simply would just allow us to allow our
domestic benefit corporations that they
choose to use that as an a place of
incor Corp and foreign corporations who
register here who have that in their
name could you could register under that
that designation that's so it's really
it's just a matter of
um they will say more of just now is it
is it a charitable trust is it a
non-profit or is it a b Corp it's a b
Corp uh yeah be Infamous B Corp yeah
Corp yeah correct yes this committee did
this committee did pass B Corps uh many
years ago and it uh
it is I guess it's it's supposed to be a
allowing the corporation to be much more
uh in in taking care of the public and
warm fuzzies for the employees and it's
almost like an ESG Corporation right it
must be I I assume PBC it's probably
been let's get good ESG scores
um well if someone elected to become a
benefit Corporation they may or may not
choose to go through what they call the
B Corporation process where they set up
a very high rigid set of Standards to be
able to note themselves as a b Corp
um but for example there are a few small
companies here in New Hampshire who just
make it a point to say that 10 of our
profits are going to go back into the
community and and they don't have to
maximize their returns to the
shareholders they're allowed to there's
a portion of their of their of their
earnings directly back to
um Prof charitable
um they provide a report once a year
that they post on our website at our on
their website and in our records this
indicate what they did with that with
those with those those funds right okay
all right so uh any questions on this
piece of Bill everybody okay
okay
um
and second in by represent McAleer
okay representative
okay
okay all those in favor about to pass
raise your hand one two three four five
six seven
okay
but we didn't do 64. and that's the
all right well we got a lot of people
for 64. so let's let's do that one oh no
we got somebody from the Department who
probably wants us to take care of her
bill first okay
all right we'll do 90 67 and then we'll
do 64 or so
okay
so wait to measure are you under
agriculture or or not labor right it
would always be why elevators were under
labor I never understood that one but
okay
um and this is
again uh housekeeping right it didn't
say you requested it but I assumed this
was you guys requested this bill
you requested this bill
Okay so
pretty
any any questions from the committee
they're pretty good
all right anybody want to make the
motion
okay
any discussion on the motion see none
all those in favor please raise your
hand one two
I will try to do better I I know I'm
foreign
yes representative field
I would move on to pass on 64. since
this is establishes a study commission
after hearing the public testimony at
the the public hearing I actually worked
with OLS on trying to develop a
legislative solution and I've actually
literally taught the course on
legislative drafting at UNH law
and this is a head scratcher that there
is no easy legislative solution to this
one uh after working with the whole us
and having
another attorney in the room we can't
figure it out and I think that's the
quintessential time when you have a
study commission trying to figure out
where do we go from here on this type of
problem
that this is only asking for a study
commission this is not actually getting
a legislative fix and given that we have
so many people in the room saying we
have a problem here we lose Nothing by
creating a study commission to take the
next step forward of asking the question
where do we go from here it may be that
there is nowhere to go from here
but our job is to listen to our
constituents and our constituents are
saying we have a problem and now we need
uh okay representative Jackson
well
I
disagree
this the the people who came before us
clearly have a remedy
in their home existing homeowners
associations agreements documents which
they signed when they put these
properties they don't like the results
and I think it is
inappropriate to try and go into those
contractual agreements between the
homeowners associations and the people
who own these properties and try and
micromanage them there are they do have
other remedies the question here is they
have other remedies they've got plenty
of other remedies they don't like them
they don't want to hire an attorney to
defend their rights and the real reason
that I object to this is because it it
opens the door to a whole series of
other things in real estate where I
don't like the results of the facts so I
want the state to come in
and modify it I don't like what I don't
like where my driveway is so I want
somebody
bigger than my next door neighbor and me
to work that out at because I don't want
to hire an attorney or a surveyor there
are so many tens of thousands of issues
like this in real estate that it is it's
a completely impractical to go it to go
into this that's my considered opinion
okay representative McAleer uh thank you
uh I actually totally agree with with uh
Sean on this uh these people came to us
last year uh they they really are
desperate they don't
they really don't have the power or the
teeth in in some of these things and and
I I think it is at least worth a study
to see if we can find something that has
the teeth in it to uh to help solve
these people's problem they they really
don't have the power
and uh if they had and whatever they
have they unfortunately don't know how
to use it so uh we there's going to be a
solution out there and I I think we we
need to find it thank you
representative Burroughs
yeah I was just trying to look it up um
is there not
um an advisory or oversight board for
condo associations or something like
that there is there well would something
like that be um appropriate well I would
say if if anything I'd say
tag it they're it
because I I don't really understand any
difference between these and a condo you
know a you know condo and a home
homeowners I'd like to hear it Sean so
to me is that if you were to say is that
just put this under that same body
uh you know that would I guess that
would make the most sense because to me
there's no difference what do you think
Sean
I thought the same however going to OLS
it's not the same for a number of
technical reasons so my initial thought
was let's just Loop these into the
chapter on condos however if we did that
for a number of technical reasons which
were explained to me we would break the
condo statute
um which would lead to disastrous
results for the state
so we would have to write a chapter a
mobile home chapter which is more work
than we can do uh on the Fly
the closest analogy actually is the
co-op statute such as your Concord Co-op
down the road but that's an imperfect
analogy to try to Loop something like a
food co-op onto mobile homes so we don't
have any Perfect Analogy to what these
actually are which is why we actually
need to create a chapter in the statutes
for what these are they're a weird
hybrid between condos and a co-op
but we don't have the perfect
legislative fix which is why we need a
study commission to try to figure out
what is this apple and orange that's
it's a pair but we don't have a pair
chapter right now in in the statutes but
if we retain the bill we could do the
same thing
we well we don't because this is a study
commission I know what I'm just saying
is that I'm just saying is if if if the
idea is we want to take what we've
already have in statute
and make it work for
manufactured housing parks
and I assume to be all all manufactured
housing Parks but I know that hb2
these features hope so at this point I'm
I'm I'm
I I I I I I there's in my mind there's
no difference between retaining a bill
and creating a study committee other
than that you've got Senators there
so uh where what was Senators bring
anything to the table or they even
whether they'll show up I don't know so
my thinking is that we're better off
just retaining and doing what you're
saying I mean I will we'll retain it and
I'll put you chair
figure something out what do you think
of that well I love being volunteers so
my Summer is gone now but I think no you
don't have to do it but the summer it's
you this doesn't start until September
but the speaker did say you could you
could uh once we we retain it that you
could begin work in June if you uh well
June it's they say he said you can do it
but then say it can't conflict with
Comedia conferences so forget that just
so it started in September and you have
uh you have two months to come up with
an answer well the problem is that this
is it's writing a chapter of in the is
not two months of work this is
legitimately
a true effort to create something that's
parallel to the condo statute is going
to take two months and it's going to
take something that's beyond the
capacity of the limited resource of the
committee that we need to actually well
that no I'm saying it's the study
committee doesn't have any more there's
no more extra resources to do a study
committee can I Wallace assist with this
what's that I mean OLS assist
OLS will need to assist because once you
draw something up you would take it to
them we're gonna we're gonna need to get
we're gonna need to get some heavy
lifting gear if we're creating something
analogous to the condo statute uh and
yeah that's assuming that the answer is
something analogous to the condo statute
we could have
there could be something that is
existing that we use
the question is what the question is
what do we need
it's assuming that there is a
legislative fix it could be write a
better contract
I think this is a great bill for you to
work on this fall great I really I think
retaining is the right idea
maybe I shouldn't okay
um
never mind I won't say that but I mean
just um and what representative Thaxton
say about you know they could hire an
attorney a lot of people don't have
money to hire an attorney well this
can't doesn't hire any attorney I know
but I'm just saying I'm with that
argument right you know um attorneys are
expensive they're like 700 an hour
yeah turn your mic on here you go the
do you understand what this thing is the
people who developed these Parks did not
have an exit strategy and the yes and
that Department of Agriculture came
along and said hey here we can do a good
thing for poor people
and so instead of having a owner you
we're going to help the owners get rid
of their white elephant the park and
we're going to finance this thing to all
of the owners and now whether you wanted
to be an owner or not
now you're a CO now you're a
153rd share of Happy Town trailer park
and that we create a board to run it
which is your Association so I can see
Sean's point this is a this is a
Heffalump it's half elephant you know
half knot
it
is there are remedies that were written
into all of those contracts for the
governing board
if you have a legitimate
CL well again back to the lawyer thing I
mean there's a lot of things you need
lawyers for that people can't afford
that's a common problem
uh but you know if you I I think if we
rather than kill the day with this thing
I would support Sean and on his
subcommittee and he's a lawyer
yeah
he'd make more money
so you know I'm happy to serve on that
committee uh I think you should as a be
in the real estate yeah and I'm familiar
with these we have several of them in
Cheshire County
personally I think every one of them was
an economic tragedy for the people who
bought who were forced into these things
but it was a great deal if you owned
owned a trailer park that you didn't
know what to do with and you were 70
years old
uh and that's what most of all of them
are
so yeah I'll deal with but I think
further from the perspective of today I
think it should be retained and sent off
to a subcommittee to study it we might
not come out with a perfect piece of
legislation we might not come out but
we'll have a better idea what the
okay okay
if
you did 100.
they could get mileage okay
representative Fila second by
uh representative Yemen has yes a poor
discussion yes
I'm uh this is not my belly Wick so I I
would not like to serve on this
subcommittee but I just wanted to
comment that uh this bill creates this
study committee it has three
State reps and three Senators it goes
until November first this year so it's
only a few months anyway it's the same
timeline as if we retained it but we did
hear from our constituents I just want
to make it clear that this bill was
heard in the Senate and all the
interested parties came in and testified
and it was heard in this room we heard
from all the interested parties uh so
you know we are making the best decision
based on the information that we've
received so
um I think retaining is uh makes the
most sense because we have
that information that we heard here and
uh any future information so
okay any more discussion on the motion
to retain
all those in favor please raise your
hand
like representative spear you're not on
this
this is a business we're 67. oh am I
looking at the wrong thing
I'm she's sorry why are you here Carrie
for the mileage
I don't think you get mileage if you're
not supposed to be here didn't I see an
I
know and then and then I read and went
back through and and uh changed it
so
okay
all right the motion passes six zip okay
so business
Herbert
uh
I don't have Burrows
right right so I have Immaculate or
Herbert filo
spear okay and well I'll tell you what
one two three I'm just looking at what
was printed here and obviously it's
wrong
uh you can vote for Herbert
all right so Spear and then Herbert and
we'll have Burrows replaces okay
one two three four five six
seven eight
is it really eight yeah there's eight
people on it okay the vote passes eight
okay
so
let's look at the bill I know we had
trouble in the beginning and that's why
okay
all right
no I said yeah
you can you can how many how many did
you find studies on this
250 how to work on this thing
does anybody want to hear it since
I don't have a problem
right
um
okay
I'll keep it simple anyhow outside of
all the research I would move itl since
the state locks power of our federal
Bill anyhow
I'll second the motion
well the idea was if that
to convince the feds to
to
do a waiver they needed some economic
evidence to do it we don't need a we
don't need a state study committee in
the state Bill to do that we're
perfectly capable of sending a letter to
Senator Shaheen and Hassan anyhow so
well glad you bring that up because I
have big issues with resolutions
so what I've always said instead of
having a resolution
is that I would keep the bill alive
in committee so people would always say
is that we're we are considering
something
but that if we but that uh so therefore
therefore when it when there's
documentation somewhere along the line
about what's going on in different
states like ncsl does report it'll say
that Commerce you know the New Hampshire
still has the bill
so that yeah we're we are conscious of
it and because I've always thought
resolutions are not worth the paper
they're printed on uh that in this way I
mean I would say over the years we would
have an issue I mean we started out way
back when
and um and the issue was uh Crow
Dickinson who was the State Rep and he
was a pro was up in your area yeah
Conway is he he's still around right is
he yeah he's the one who got arrested at
the airport yeah for having a gun in his
car in his bag yeah but anyway so Crow
the issue was that people from the main
tax guys would come into the state and
audit uh appliance stores and and
businesses that were selling and seeing
whether they were uh not charging the
sales tax
and the issue was sales tax collection
and uh so obviously we were never going
to pass that bill I mean that's you know
there's a reciprocity but we always kept
the bill alive we always retained we
always kept the bill alive so that he
could always say well you know we're
we're very concerned about this issue
and then we're we have it and we're
worrying we're working on it but of
course now we have YouTube and they now
heard from my motives
but they'll never find us on YouTube
right well everything's on YouTube but
we could you could also equally say that
the Senate passed the bill by whatever
both the Senate passed the bill by
I suppose the other wisdom of retaining
this bill is who knows what happens we
put something under the floor of the
house
so we would have another bite at it
anyways come you know next year in
October where we have to make it much
decide
again what to do with it
so
I have a I think the bill should be
retained and go into a pile that says it
should never see the light of day and
the reason I say that is I actually did
the investigation to find out what the
impact of Jones Act was on our heating
bills and our electricity
and it turns out it's in the case of
heating bills there is no impact in the
case of uh electricity
it's if you compare it to some of the
other things and JP Morgan is big into
this investment and they did the
analysis and it's on the PA in the order
of one or two cents but the problem we
have is that right now the buyer for
electricity supply and demand for
natural gas is Europe and China and
they're paying two and three times the
price we pay as a result of that no
supplier is going to sell to us if they
can get more money overseas
foreign
settles out and who knows when that will
ever happen any analysis we do now is a
joke it is no validity at all so this
thing should be retained and on top of
that they wanted 250 000 of taxpayer
money to investigate something that you
can find out online
retain it so it never sees the light of
day
if we put it out on the floor
there are people who will not have done
the investigation that I tried to do
and they will make snap judgments based
on whatever now you may not like the
Jones act because it is protectionist
fine you may like it because it is
protectionist fine but what impact did
it have on the cost of our yearly
heating nothing and so therefore it
okay representative spear second by
representative hunt moves to retain is
there any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor raise
okay how is that possible
okay
you get it all all right
115.
all right I gotta go see it I gotta go
yeah
trellis jealous
foreign
up the subcommittee work section for
Insurance legislation
and first one I see is Senate Bill 31
technical changes so the law is
community members
I just highlighted us okay
yeah we have to have these oh there it
all right it is
no representative Terry
all right
we can pose
silly and
bro
no Vincent
and
it's
embarrass
okay
it is what it is yep okay
all right
for Terry
okay
all right so this is uh Property and
Casualty
insurance department
say 402 412 15 and 20.
okay
does anybody have any questions or
all right so
um I have
Terry's not here I have post purcelli
hunt collabro
Vincent's not here
Gibbs
here in Burrows
I can take a shot
well I like to pair so how many
Republicans am I missing I'm missing
Terry
yeah so if we take
so we have Vincent so so
he's gonna
because
okay so I'm going to
I have
a spear
is replacing Gibbs
okay chairman all right who would like
I was going to ask if you wanted me to
replace uh something no I I if I don't
have to replace if I can do uh pairing
okay then I pair okay
so okay
so uh anybody want to make the motion uh
all right I'll make it representative
hunt
second by representative patusek
moves ought to pass
seeing none all those in favor raise
okay
post purcelli I don't have Walsh on this
list
okay so one two three four
by six
all right
I I like
raise your hand so someone's confusing
me okay well I do have a show and I do
and I do have a post
and I do have
sitting there we go one two three four
five
[Music]
oh yeah I don't have you on here for two
SEC
you're not subbing at this moment I
appeared paired it out
all right next one
yes
okay that was second by representative
Burroughs
okay
uh next up Senate Bill 82 related to
uh I think this is really a bear that
because
and there's there's so much going on
here
representative spear
just just a comment
the New Hampshire bulletin they had a uh
report that said that Anthem owed 300
million dollars on unpaid claims
weeks long delays and hospitals were
screaming and having all kinds of
problems right so
I I would assume the insurance
department is going to be investigating
this right I mean
they're on top of it so I would say that
we retain it we'll find out in September
yeah
so what do you want to do
we change it and waiting to see what the
what do I do
yeah okay all right now everybody can
join in now okay so representative
okay
and who else I have missing I have
Representative Vincent is going to be
replaced by spear
representative Gibbs is going to be
and
uh
alrighty so one two three four five six
seven eight
okay
all right who would like to make the
motion
okay
yes
any discussion on the retained motion
see none all those in favor raise your
hand
okay so I'm writing on here is the
insurance department will be reporting
okay
all right next up is Senate Bill 99
relative responsibilities insurers and
conducting reviews of operations
administrators
okay so the question was posed I think
actually you posted and uh so um I asked
the interested party to drop an
amendment that will ensure that the
on-site visit uh or a virtual audit can
occur
okay
any discussion on the amendment to
Senate Bill 99 number
okay
uh representative hunt seconded by
that moves ought to pass on the
amendment any discussion on the motion
see none all those in favor of capacity
eight
eat nothing
okay representative hunt
uh ought to pass as amended
any discussion on the motion
see none all those in favor raise your
hand
okay
the
so representative hunt seconded by
moves ought to pass
any discussion on the motion
okay
yeah what's wrong with those Senators
they should be saying anything more
excited
I think the next two are the next next
okay
okay now we get to the middle
whoever meets the road okay Senate Bill
190 direct the insurance department to
connect a cost study of providing
coverage uh for certain reproductive
anybody want to weigh in
although I'm not on the subcommittee I
would urge my colleagues to make an
lgbtq couples are already paying for
this benefit but are unable to access it
because of the sex of their partner
therefore this is in effect
discrimination on the basis of sex
because they are unable to access a
benefit for which they're paying simply
due to the the sex of their partner
this doesn't obligate the state to do
anything it is simply asking the state
to study the economic impact if they
were if we were to pass such a bill
the type of legislation that we pass
signals the type of values that we have
as a state and particularly in the type
of political climate that we have right
now with so much anti-lgbtq violence and
rhetoric happening across the country
it's important that as a state we signal
that we value lgbtq equality which I
believe we do as a state
enacting such a steady commission which
costs us nothing which doesn't actually
require us to provide this coverage but
says that we wish to investigate such
coverage
is a powerful signal that we do value
this type of equality and that we think
that these couples should be able to
start a family so I would urge my
colleagues to
okay
I've given a lot of thought to it
um and I do feel that this particular
population should have the ability to at
least have a rider we should be looking
at and evaluating these options I feel
that the commission would be a good way
anybody else
I agree completely with representative
filio and again we're seeing this across
the country and again this this is a
statement I think if we fail to go
forward with the cost study we are
making a statement about our values and
about how we
um
how we respect or don't respect the LBG
LBGTQ community so I'm in agreement with
okay
um so
Jeremy yes representative perhaps I'm
the only one here who either remembers
or didn't understand
when we initially heard this bill in
questioned uh one
or heard from and I don't know whether
we questioned or not uh with the
individuals who spoke in response to a
question about single individuals
undergoing assisted reproduction care
introduced the term socially infertile
and I'm wondering I I don't understand
what socially infertile means wondering
if somebody can under explain to me what
somebody
do we have anyone here today
um an expert who can because we don't
need to you know representative Phelan
I would actually defer to representative
collaber who I think is a healthcare
as a health care provider
um
when you place a situation of a couple
that are not able to procreate in and
about themselves that is a social
a social situation where they cannot
they are infertile by virtue of that
to women
two men
but what about individuals individuals
my understanding is they don't want to
or maybe they are not comfortable having
intercourse and this is their only way
to be able to have children I've had
women who were traumatized and that was
how they chose to have kids
okay
so um
I was waiting for everybody else to
weigh in and then
so we pass infertility mandate
um but four years ago
and when we passed it my memory was that
it was a handful of States Massachusetts
was the most famous of having
infertility coverage but I would venture
to Guess that there are not more than
four or five states total
okay number six
no no no no no you don't understand this
we already passed it
infertility coverage
Okay so
that is a health insurance mandate
there are no writers when it comes to
health insurance because a writer is
you're you end up paying for the whole
class anyways because the only person
who takes a writer is someone who's
going to use the benefit so to forget
about writers what this committee deals
with is health insurance mandates that
everybody is paying
for this benefit
okay even though we don't get it in
other words the the most famous the
original mandate was that uh insurance
companies could not rate women higher
than men
even though most people said women have
more
Health needs because they do May babies
and that's but that everyone says is
that that was the very one of the Year
first mandates okay
mandates are have a cost
absolutely to have a cost
in terms of calculating that cost okay
has to be some statistical
calculations based upon who's going to
take advantage of it how many are out
there uh uh but in
most cases I would say I've never had a
mandate that said let's calculate how
many people are actually going to take
advantage of it it usually was what will
be the cost of it
okay what is just the cost of of the
Mandate okay so it's it's a very unusual
circumstance so what I want to start
with is just on the premises that
if you're asking for equality
that
if a gay couple
if
they're infertile
they still get the Mandate mandates
available to them
right now the state law allows them so
we're not treating anybody differently
it has nothing to do your middle steps
it has to do with whether you are
infertile
period
theoretically they can get the coverage
because the Mandate the infer the
infertility mandate coverage doesn't say
anything about marital status
so they're already covered
as long as they are infertile you are
changing this legislation
from not infertile
you're basically saying anybody
regardless of their
marital sets right should be allowed
to get infertility coverage
representative to some extent that
aligns the question that K couples or
lgbtq couples are inherently infertile
because no matter how intimate they are
you're looking at the actual biological
the two people I mean I would I would
say is
um not that I'm a scientists but the
idea of two Y chromosomes okay somewhere
else you got to go get the X chromosome
to be in there right somewhere again I'm
naive to this
but somehow you're still going to have
to get that from somewhere else that is
what is true
under our mandate that we have in
fertility coverage that whatever that
person is missing
the infertility is going to go find it
somewhere else and it'll be part of the
process of the in vitro however neither
partner is literally infertile that's
that's the problem here
unless one of the partners literally was
infertile which is unlikely to be the
case in any circumstance
so in all due respect
is that um I think this is actually even
though you're saying you're looking at
is showing respect to these people who
are obviously you know that that there's
a momentum across this country but I
would say is that is dangerous because
you're actually doing exactly what those
people who are afraid of which is is
dispensation you're taking infertility
and say we don't care whether you're
infertile we're going to give it to
anyone who's gay
and that is not true
for a heterosexual couple in a
heterosexual couple infertility coverage
is only if somebody is infertile so I
would say is I really don't think this
is a good idea
to pass this because I lastly we want to
tell everybody is that we're now going
special that nobody else had that every
so I know we usually like to be talk
about fairness we want to do equal
what's fair
and I'm saying under our current statute
now for infertility coverage it is fair
for everybody
there is no sexual no
discrimination going on under our
current statute
perhaps that's the great question to put
to a study committee right so I would
I think this is a great question then to
put to the floor of the house no it will
is if this is I mean I I'm my sense this
is a 10 10 vote oh gosh
I know but we're gonna
okay so you're not going to vote to
so your our deal was is off now
you really want to have this debate on
the floor
no we don't want to have this debate on
there is an because of the the
definition of social infertility which
means that they're both fertile but
because of the
in the in that case this the Sexes are
the same so socially they can't have a
child
naturally
does bring up a point
and while I want to support the lbgt
if they we're the pro to me the way the
problem comes in is if the couple are
both transgendered
then they probably can't have kids at
all
what in that case I would ask would the
insurance cover that case they're
they're definitely infertile
would the insurance cover a
uh because they are physically unable
um
yeah
I don't even know how many of that
applies to
yeah you know I'm just because you said
well because you're assuming that that
they have have had a surgical procedure
that caused them to be infertile right
um I I don't have the bill in front of
us anybody have the bill in front of
them the current excuse me the current
law I do not believe it says anything
because you're saying I'm listening to
you and I'm hearing you say that we
already have measures in place statutes
in place to cover and now I'm hearing
from the other side well no we really
don't
so lose right it's correct and it's
incorrect
and doesn't this ineffective thanks for
a little more work
representative Burroughs and I also
would question why if if I'm sorry am I
going to get well before we go into the
next question can we get an answer to my
question oh okay I'm sorry no that's
good how many have been out of the speed
effect
how do we know how do we know
yeah so this is the spot the
sponsors
you just uh make sure the mic is on and
you pull it real close to yourself
um I'm Catherine Tucker can you hear me
yeah okay and I practice uh infertility
um
so in terms of the chair is correct that
a same-sex couple who has medical
infertility is going to be covered under
the current bill however most folks
don't go into trying to have a baby
knowing that they have medical
infertility they go in and they start
trying and if it doesn't work after a
certain period of time or if there's you
know a semen analysis that comes back
with poor motility or something that's
how they would discover that they in
fact have a medical infertility so what
this is is this the cost study would be
looking at expanding the coverage to
start for infertile cup I'm sorry to
start for same-sex couples right with
their very first time of trying so for
female couples that is typically in
insemination that takes place at the OB
gyn's office and for male couples that
would be the process of forming embryos
that would later be used with a
gestational carrier and right now a
hundred percent of my clients that are
coming to me who are female couples or
male couples do not have coverage to
start the process a small portion of
them do not have success and then become
eligible to as medically internal to
start the process and so at that point
they would get coverage and you know
there's some a whole bunch of issues
there also but that I think we can work
administratively with the insurance
chairman
yes
thank you right in in thinking this
thing through
um I was puzzled I wondered how far it
went does it go as far as as using a
surrogate
and if you use the surrogate
I don't think the bill should pay the
fee for the surrogate but the surrogate
was presumably have medical coverage
themselves and that that part would be
covered the birthing process does it
mean that go that far this is only for
medical costs so any fees paid to the
surrogate would not be included and in
addition our current infertility law
does not cover embryo transfers to the
surrogate so that is something that's
always going to be cash pay out of
pocket for the patients for whatever
reason that they need to turn to a
surrogate so this is just for the
medical costs of getting the eggs
getting the sperm making the embryos
which is called the in vitro process is
vitro okay that's the key word here is
in vitro yes for for the men that's what
they need for the female couples they
can start with insemination which is a
much lower
um less lower Tech technical process
um and much cheaper but the bottom line
is we don't know what these things are
going to cost and based on what I know I
think right it's actually going to be a
money saver to for to the carriers
because based on how we've seen things
well if if the insurance companies could
save money then they don't need to be
mandated they would do that on their own
and that's what the purpose of the cost
studies let's see what this costs and
maybe then that study going to work how
do we how we what do we get I mean I
guess I mean we could start with so
exactly how much has this mandate cost
us so far
that would I think that that would be
one factor I mean we're talking about
the experts the actual experts who can
use their knowledge so figure this out
again I would argue we don't need a
study committee to do that this
committee can get those kind of
questions answered
we don't need a study committee and and
I'm just saying that you know I know you
guys think study committees are great
things but someone who's done plenty of
study caves in my time that unless you
have specific language that you want
them to come back with the statute we
have a separate law on our books right
now that allows us as a committee to
order the department to do an economic
study okay and uh I guess I should know
the RSA but um I mean I I refer to the
lobbyist who who came up with it you
know Liz Murphy and I called the Liz
Murphy law but it was uh it was the
intent is that yes we as a committee
can be specific in asking the department
to come back with what something costs
what what is the economic cost going to
be my problem with this bill is it's so
wide open when you put in single
are you going to then say some you're
going to expect an insurance department
to do a calculation of how many single
people might want to have children
are we being asked to do this on the
basis of anecdotal
uh evidence or surmised or projected
evidence rather than actual
cases numbers of people who have been
denied
in your in your views uh what's going on
so people aren't even getting denied and
the reason is that the fertility clinics
won't even submit the request to the
insurance company so there's no denial
records how do you know this that's what
I'm asking I talk with the I talk with
clients patients I talk with doctors I
talk with people at the fertility
clinics
What's the magnitude of the problem
every single female couple and every
single male couple who's looking to
procreate as well as single individuals
magnitude means the size the number I
can't I can't give you a number but I'm
happy to go and look into that and see
what we can come up with
um that would be helpful yes are we
talking about hundreds thousands tens
yes that would be helpful yes I don't
know that right now I don't know how big
a problem we have if we have a problem I
don't even know if you have a problem
change
representative
yes I'm sorry it would seem that that's
a perfect question to put to a study
committee
yeah what is the scope of the problem
right so right now under our statute did
to require that ask the returns
department to do that economic study it
has to come from this committee it
cannot come from a study committee
you'll be part of the economic part of
the economic study would be first to
determine the scope of what is the
economic and I'm telling you you're
speaking to him retaining because under
our this way the statue right you know
the Murphy Law works it's not a study
committee requesting it it has to be
requested by a actual standing committee
and I think it even says Congress in the
statute I don't know
yes representative spirit I I've had a
problem with a lot of the study
committees that we've that we've tried
to set up I mean that have been asked
for with various bills
and it has been my feeling all along
that if we don't know the scope of the
problem
then we don't have any business studying
it
I think that retaining it and investing
and asking the insurance company to
investigate it is good
but just willy-nilly throwing study
committees out there without even
knowing if there was a problem I have a
problem with because then in fact
this this the uh taxpayers are paying
for that and we should know what the
size of that is I'm I'm sorry that's I I
don't go along with study committees
that don't have a scope you're okay with
retaining absolutely I think I think
it's a very worthwhile thing to start to
understand
would you be okay with retaining so that
we could work on it
I'd move itl
I would move itl
what's your rationale for Ito
so that that that's an opinion that's
been asked for not emotion so are we
going to get through a motion uh yeah no
I I want to retain it I wanted I wanted
I truly want to know more about it for
myself personally
I am dying to know how much this mandate
has cost us so far Mr chairman I voted
against this mandate when we passed it
four years ago so the opportunity to
have a economic study to see how much
this how much we paid for it I think is
is a wonderful idea so so I I I I'm not
saying I would ask you not to that's not
Ito that's retained this and and you can
take that up and come come November or
you know October
if if if we're not at that place if you
want to then send it to the floor then
I'd say that send it to the floor at
that point with an itl motion but at
this point I think it's worth retaining
it first Mr chair are you moving there I
I I I I I'm this is the subcommittee
we're trying to you know kind of work
work for consensus we want to have kids
see you the rest of the afternoon yeah I
I would make the motion to retain okay
okay I'm just I'm gonna say if I could
make a comment I hate to admit it but
John Mr Hunt just made some good points
I really hate to admit it but he has to
the beach
can I ask a question one question yes
how hard is it to get the to ask the
insurance company to give us a course
number uh
please you say please
in that case I'll say please I I believe
that all I have to do is uh is request
it and I think I know in writing do you
I know for this in writing I think it's
all I have to do is just say I just I
can ask
oh the committee does have to take a
vote to refer it okay I knew there was a
I knew that you had to come from the
committee so thank you Alex for looking
up the statute okay so so we will work
on a request of you know through the
department until we can then vote that
in the committee
okay
all right representative post second by
representative Calabro moves uh to
retain any discussion on the motion
see none all those in favor uh please
eight zip
okay
um and I'm going to write here on our
comments is that
um
the committee uh
committee
needs
for what is it what is it called what is
actual real study
okay
okay on to another mandate
religious Services provided through a
so
John why don't you come up take a seat
here
if I understand this correctly
that a primary care physician
would be Consulting with a
Psychotherapy psychologist
and the psychologist says yes Xanax is
recommended
then the primary care physician because
they have the rights to order
prescriptions could then order that
thank you Mr chair the uh
a psychologist is not licensed to
prescribe medication so they can't do
that so they would not if a psychologist
felt there was a medication assessment
that was needed they would refer the
primary care physician to a psychiatrist
they would refer to it they would they
would suggest the primary care
physicians speak with a psychiatrist
through the collaborative care model
which is a different model but similar
so why why is it some people think that
it looks like a psychologists are
involved in prescription drugs with this
bill why has that been accusation been
made by the psychiatrist
well I've spoken with a psychiatrist and
have not heard that it's a talking point
I can tell you that there was there is
nothing in here that suggests that
psychologists are or request
psychologists be involved in prescribing
medication it's just it's not part of
the S Copa practice
okay so why do we need this bill
wait a minute so representative Calabro
you have very strong opinions I'd say
yeah I've actually experienced this and
it de-escalates situations and it
prevents patients from going into the
emergency room and using resources that
would otherwise have gone to somebody in
an actual emergency need so if I'm
sitting here with a patient who's at PQ
PA you're a psychologist no I'm a
provider we've had somebody roomed
they've got a behavioral emergency with
a phq score
all right of of an elevated number it
lets me know this person has an o is at
an elevated risk for a behavioral
emergency every single person in
medicine knows how to deal with that
okay we all have protocols about what we
do
we either send them to the emergency
room or God bless we have somebody on
call we can call them down to help and
de-escalate the situation so I'm not
sitting with that patient for 40 minutes
I'm stay I'm staying on time now I've
got a psychologist who can de-escalate
teach them the coping skills they need
get them to where they need to be then
they can come back to me and have an
actual meaningful discourse and we can
make a treatment plan going forward that
will oftentimes involve psychologists
psychiatry
because I don't feel comfortable being
Psychiatry alone though that is
basically what I was forced to do in
mobile crisis for the state
I'm telling you this is this is going to
save a lot of resources it's not a bad
choice
it's logarithmically growing across the
country we're trained to do it it's a
very effective model so why isn't this
already occurring why do we have this
fighting everywhere so why do we need
this legislation
because apparently they haven't gotten
the clue
who
I would say the insurance companies so
you're saying the insurance companies
are refusing
what what did they refuse what what part
of this process
primary I'm seeing a patient you're
you're supposed to refer someone to I
will refer them emergently to Psychiatry
for a particular score I'm also going to
have a psychologist go in and see them
they will have spent 45 minutes
de-escalating with a patient they can't
bill for it now I can go in and take
care of them medically I'm going to
prescribe whatever medications are
needed to stabilize them until we can
get them to Psychiatry I can bill for
them that's the problem
what wait a minute again we're talking
about the primary care physician
making a referral
so why when they just refer to the
psychiatrists if if you mean isn't
Psychiatry doesn't have openings like
that
what do you mean by openings they aren't
going to be available for sometimes two
and three months
there's a shortage John that's why we
need these people so you're looking for
the psychologists
to de-escalate a situation to give them
the coping skills they need so they lead
us medication I will Bridge them until
they can meet with psychiatry and we
will have a treatment plan with a
psychologist usually the one that I just
brought in as an on-call basis is a soft
handoff it's part of the collaborative
matter the model
It's very effective for people with a
very small limited number of staff
that's why we do it right you get okay
so because we had the last time we had a
collaborative bill it was it was
basically
um you know it was intervening in what
is now the current practice which is the
referral process
so it was a tag team
this is actually a little more
collaborative and integrated
this is a lot more but then we're
practicing medicine like this is
something that's got to be decided by
the Board of Medicine
this is not what we do I think this
isn't that complicated okay
representative field
a true question is the problem here then
that the psychologist lacks a billing
code
to be able to bill for their time if the
primary care physician does that
referral for that what do you mean like
the billing time uh billing code let's
say the primary care physician does that
quick referral for a de-escalation to
the psychologist
is the problem here then that the
psychologist lacks a billing code for
that quick referral on for that
de-escalation time so John
yes and thank you for the question so
there's multiple problems here the the
the the problem the representative was
speaking to is the urgency of the
situation it's an emergent situation in
either a professional needs to be
available to engage with a client to
de-escalate them hopefully they'll Skype
them or they're going to be in an
emergency room or an inpatient unit
that's the that's the urgency of the
issue the in terms of the billing codes
so when we started this process we
reached out to Anthem and we reached out
to 0.32 and we've had a number of
conversations and those conversations
have continued to some extent and
they've picked up over the last couple
of days
Anthem first forwarded to my client a
list of building codes applicable to
psychiatrists and psychologists
the consultation codes were applicable
to psychiatrist contracts they were
listed as not applicable to psychologist
contracts so we raised that with Anthem
and Anthem told my client that that was
a surprise to them that they believed
that psychologists could be built could
bill for these coats
the problem is we've been having this
conversation since October November and
really haven't
haven't gotten any clearer resolution
about whether a psychologist can or
cannot bill for consultation
that's why my client did a survey with
practicing psychologists in the field 86
percent of the psychologists who
responded said that they either did not
bill
for consultation codes or were denied
for consultation codes when we when they
were asked why didn't you Bill most of
them were told that historically they've
been denied for consultation codes and
they stopped billing because it wasn't
worth the effort now
insurance I don't come here a lot for
good reason insurance is a very complex
issue and you folks are the experts on
that I believe that Anthem and point 32
and good faith told us they believe
these should be covered but I do know
from my clients that they are not
covered
I can't bridge that divide to know where
the truth lies but what I do know is
that this is a newer model
of uh of integrated care collaborative
care being the other more common model
from my clients to have Primary Care
practices set up
set up agreements with them the primary
care practices are going to want to know
that these are reimbursable codes and
that they're endorsed by the legislature
and the insurance companies that's what
they're going to want to know before
they'll even set up a contract or even
have that conversation
what this bill is intended to do very
simply is to establish this as a valid
model of integrated care and it says
throughout that the primary care
practices do not need to use this they
can say well we don't use it
what we believe in practice though is
that collaborative care which is with a
psychiatrist as the consultant and
Primary Care Behavioral Health which is
as a non a licensed non-sychiatrist as
the consultant work very well in tandem
for the ex for the very first question
you asked
psychologists social workers can't
prescribe medication and are not looking
for the ability to prescribe medication
so anytime medication is a likely
alternative
then it needs to be a psychiatrist
working with the primary care doctor
the problem with the primary care
doctors have though is that they're not
experts in Behavioral Health
they have a rotation they have some
training in medical school maybe they
have more clients with mental health
issues than they want
but they're not experts and a colleague
of mine used to say
when a hammer is the only tool you have
that's the tool you use
for primary care doctors medication is
their hammer
and you heard from
one of the psychologists who testified
that in some cases she mentioned panic
attacks specifically medication can be
detrimental
to the long-term recovery
so this is not about
you know psychologists looking to do
things that they don't do already
this is about trying to service the
patients of the state who have a
significant mental health need we we
talk all the time I don't know about
this committee but we talk in many other
committees about the workforce crisis
there is a significant mental health
Workforce crisis
it is going to take years if not longer
to remedy that I mean I'm working on
other legislation to try to address that
but it's going to take years to remedy
the Mental Health crisis what this bill
in front of you is is a bridge to that
eventuality of building out the system
why is it a bridge well it's a bridge
because psychologists have three and
four month waiting periods
recently I needed my own therapy I
reached out I could not get an
appointment for at least four months
at that point the situational crisis was
resolved and there's no need for it but
for folks who were in in a much more
debilitated situation it's not they
can't wait three or four months they
can't wait three or four days
so this sets up a system where you're
not looking for long-term therapy you're
looking for an emergency intervention by
a trained behavioral health professional
to at the hopefully
hopefully eliminate the need for
hospitalization or emergency care that's
the that's the goal but at the very
least help them to extend out for a few
days until maybe they need another
follow-up appointment maybe they have to
be referred by this by the pcbh
professional outside of the primary care
to a mental health Community Mental
Health Center or you know what have you
to bridge them so that they can not be
hospitalized or spend weeks in the
emergency room I don't think any one of
us at least of all the insurance
companies want to see patients in the
emergency room needlessly because they
can't get mental health care it is far
I do have my question oh did they ever
external review this is like the most
important legislation I've ever passed
on health care and that is that when
you've been denied
you request a review external review
it's are you talking about the
psychologists
any physician who requested insurance
company denies it
you then go through external review I'm
I cannot answer I don't have the
information I can reach out to the
psychologist and ask that it would have
been several years ago but I can't
answer it right so here's here's what my
problem with this bill is okay and that
is we're talking about a model
a behavioral model this is a methodology
okay in in schools they call it the
pedagogy okay this is a pet a pedagogy
of which we're going to use to for
mental health services okay so the
question now becomes when I read the
bill it says in here that it's the
primary care provider who gets to choose
no it says it says on page two it says
the application the actual only mandate
insurance coverage of such care if a
primary care provider were to choose
this model
okay so now what we're saying is that
all our Managed Care statutes are based
upon the medical director the Board of
Medicine so what are the the appropriate
protocols the appropriate different
behavioral methods but now we're
mandating one
if a physician chooses it
okay the last thing you want is have
health insurance companies to start
saying no we're not going to use that
physician because they've chosen
something that we don't think is
appropriate manner of care may I so I'm
just asking can't we just turn this into
a May
this just say they can do this method
that we're being supportive of the
concept of this care
okay and that yes it is a is a it is a
conversation between the primary care
physician and the insurance company okay
and that again this is where I'm talking
about external review if the primary
care physician thinks this is the
appropriate care for the patient to use
this model yes then we have a system in
place where they ask the insurance
company
to do it
and the insurance company can make a
choice and say whether you know if not
then you have the external review which
does is a whole process with outside
external review where people come in and
say and evaluate the case and say
whether it was really appropriate to or
not
so all I'm asking says is to just is
changing a couple words here from the
ACT shall
mandate
all right and then I was up here
um where are you representative yeah I'm
on page two yeah
an application
and then up on on the top of the page
insurance provider uh
you shall okay line eight I guess
everybody's got the numbered one so if
you print them on the computer so on
page two line eight says yeah shall not
deny the coverage on the sole basis that
the service delivered through the
primary care Behavior no no because
that might not the the protocol the
insurance company if they have their own
they have their own
uh medical director for psychology right
so their their medical that that's the
person who makes the call
right so all I'm saying is is just let
the process let what we use for
everything else when it comes to our
health insurance you know there's our
benefits in terms of the process of the
medical director the board of you know
and then with Consulting Department what
of what is what I get the generally
accepted medical appropriate care
is I think is the concept
and all I'm asking is is change those
words rather than it being a mandate to
being that okay this is something that
can be done and I it would
I could live with it
wow
because we're not changing anything and
we are not we are not determining health
care for somebody else that's just not
we're yet you might say we know a lot
about insurance but you know we've made
mistakes when we come to mandates in the
past
yes so there's lots of things going on
in those questions and there's lots of
things going on so I had the opportunity
to meet with Alex Feld Babel for the
insurance department last week
incredibly helpful in terms of helping
me understand some of the questions that
the committee had
I just drafted some changes to this bill
okay that my client signed off on
yesterday I shared it with
um Point 32 and Anthem yesterday okay it
was yesterday we haven't had a chance to
get back together and talk about it
again which we're planning to do to to
talk about it what you're talking about
was one of the things so the application
section was added in total by the that
Senate chair at the last minute we
hadn't seen or vetted that language
before she added it so that second
sentence you're referring to we've
already talked to Anthem about just
taking that entire second sentence out
that's good good but you know this okay
so the other pieces that we think can
tighten this bill up significantly but
so let's have another subcommittee on
this
okay so we'll do next Wednesday we'll
actually representative Terry has a
question
we're gonna have another meeting yes
about this yes
well well good because the longer this
goes on the more questions occur to me
such that I do not have enough sticks to
shake at all of them as you know the
saying goes shake a stick so but I've
always wondered what it meant yes so uh
but my question one of them at 20
minutes ago
and let me go back to that one because
now there are 19 more but we're talking
about
representative Calabro is is is is in
the emergency room and she wants to call
down a psychologist to come and
de-escalate a situation
and perhaps get engaged in some behavior
modification calm the person down maybe
the person then
um with the continuing care of the
primary care physician collabro Dr
Calabro May then see the need to refer
to a psychiatrist the problem here that
is being described is one of money
in insurance that the psychologists is
is not getting paid
and what I heard was that you have been
in conversations with insurance
companies since October and have heard
from them that they don't have a problem
with this but that but they're not doing
it right but so so the question is and I
guess I've just been a parent too long I
want to bring the other party in here
and I want to hear from the insurance
companies as to why it is that they
haven't
rendered a decision
that we can then deal with because we're
here as legislators as a last resort if
all else fails
and I I'm not sure that all else has
failed at this point because I'm not
sure that the insurers have given us any
reason whatsoever for why they're not
doing this
you're claiming that they're not doing
it I don't dispute that but the question
is why are they not admitting that
they're not doing anything and telling
us why they're not doing anything that's
what we need to hear from I mean you can
pass this along second or third hand and
it becomes interesting today because we
are going to deal with this next
Wednesday because the chair is going to
call another subcommittee meeting but I
would love to hear from the insurance
companies as to why they're putting you
and and Dr Calabro in this situation
such that you're not happy you can have
this model if you want to the question
is you're not getting certain parties or
players are not getting paid and that's
what we have to deal with and the
question is is it because there's an
unwillingness on the part of insurance
companies to do this and if so let them
come forward and tell us that they're
unwilling to do it and why they're
unwilling to do it let me be really
clear I don't speak to the insurance
companies and so I was very careful to
say that the insurance companies have
told us that these Co they believe these
codes
ought to are reimbursable they couldn't
answer the question why they're not and
that's been the conversation so they did
not support this they did not oppose the
idea of this billing they're trying to
get their arms around it that's why
these conversations are ongoing I don't
see the insurance companies at this
point as unwilling participants I see
the insurance companies as having Frank
conversations with us to the extent that
they're able to since October
yeah the other piece is my rocket
science I would disagree that this
committee or this legislature is a
quarter last but you saw it I believe
this this Committee in this legislature
set public policy that then the private
entities follow and that's that's the
reason we're here if need be because
something's not working the question is
the Florida medicine I'm sorry this is
this is not we don't set this kind of
policy this is this is protocols
practice of the medical system that our
job is not to intervene in that level so
would you like the board of psychology
to say that um I want to hear that the
external review didn't that they took it
to external review and here's the
refusal letter and it's let's find out
exactly get down to the Brass tax on why
and why and who's saying telling them
I'm happy to try to get that answer from
me that's what I'm interested yes
representative
um you're talking about external review
you don't mean at the time that there's
a crisis
the external review is I have to uh when
the the paperwork is filed and sent in
yeah and to get reimbursement yeah and
the insurance company declines it
okay then that we external review
happens within a month
you know he's saying there's a denial
and I I'm just shocked but shocked I
looked at the external review I'm saying
that our psychologists when surveyed
many of them said they did not submit
reimbursement at all when asked why they
didn't submit reimbursement they said
that historically they've been denied so
I don't know what historically means and
I would have to try to figure that out
look at so why wouldn't we want to make
it easier for them to get real no no no
no no no no no we have a system you come
to us when the system is failing if
somebody is fail is not is refusing to
file it that's not our problem you know
I don't think they're talking about
filing filing filing they never filed it
we stopped filing for it because we were
asked to stop you have a letter that
says no accounts receipt accounts
payable gives us calls and says we're
not getting paid for this stop filing
for it it's just making extra work for
us
uh again that means there was a refuels
letter somebody got their a list of
benefits and said it was refused Mr
chairman yeah
the insurance company is here could we
have them come up and tell us why we're
the insurance company Okay who wants to
do it
okay here we go so we got Harvard and
Anthem Mr chairman while there is an
approach being made and there's a moment
I also circled certain uh and maybe this
is what's being worked on I I circled
certain words and phrases with questions
consultation with a physician the
question was rayed what does this mean
in person or on the phone and then I
circled appropriate CPT codes what are
appropriate CPT codes so this begs for
retaining but I I I'm very eager to hear
you did ask for retaining when in your
okay so so we have been engaged in
conversations with New Hampshire psych
Association I would clarify that in the
fall I was asked sort of in a vacuum for
a list of codes not knowing what it was
going to be used for and so I think it's
a slight mischaracterization to make it
sound like we've been working on really
drilling down in the issue since October
it's really more recently and as I said
last time I was here
this is very similar to the
collaborative care model where providers
were not using the codes we sat around a
table with the insurance department and
other stakeholders and we figured out
what the problem was it was a practical
issue I think this is very similar where
providers aren't using the codes how can
we reimburse for them so I think there's
probably education that needs to happen
there might need to be updates to
contracts but conceptually this is not
an issue of carriers not wanting to
cover it that's just my short response I
don't know if you
uh and so again I'm kind of coming in
new to this I do know that Harvard
Pilgrim part of 0.32 Health uh much like
Anthem had discussions with the
association back last fall
um about this um I wasn't part of that
and now my understanding is that these
are things that we think are covered uh
the providers seem to think that they're
not
um and I think that's one of the biggest
disputes and so
um I talked with Mr dejoy earlier and
we'll continue with chat and I asked to
be involved with that because I not
being part of the discussions back in
October November I I don't know but
those some of the questions we have is
what does this involve and we think
these are covered and show us that
they're not or tell us where they're not
so we can check it out
okay Mr chairman anybody has a question
yes representative post yes thank you Mr
chairman um so I have a question
um can I get your names everybody keeps
coming up without a name sorry about
that I'm Sabrina Dunlap director of
government relations for Anthem okay
and I'm Peter Bragdon I'm with uh party
strategies here in Concord representing
Harper Pilgrim Healthcare a part of
Point 32 health thank you so my question
to you is between think and no you said
you think
but you should know that they're covered
or not you shouldn't have to think
whether it's covered if you have it in a
policy
I assume it would be there is that
correct
again I'm just coming into this really
based on the public hearing from was it
last week or the week before so it is
all new to me my understanding is these
are things that are covered but again
every situation is different you'll give
in my view I'd like to have and there
was a good case example given earlier
today of here's a situation in an
emergency room bringing a psychologist
to de-escalate right that's a concrete
example and so bring up that in
discussion and say okay is this covered
or is it not and that's pretty easy to
answer that I don't know that sitting
here I'm a lobbyist I'm not a health
insurance person but that's one of the
things I want to talk about
I can say I did look at specific codes
there's there's many and I think part of
the challenge is there's there appears
to be some disagreement around what
quotes even qualify as being part of
this model so I can say I know we
covered a cover a number of the codes
that come in this list there might be
disagreement among providers among the
psych Association among carriers about
what should qualify as this model but in
terms of the actual service it is
covered
foreign
okay so what's really important to me is
that if we're going to pass legislation
telling me something it is supposed to
make a bright line to clarify what
people think or don't think or know or
don't know and so that a proper process
is occurring because otherwise all we're
just doing is opening up a new can of
worms that they'll be back next year
saying it it didn't work or no
misinterpreted or we don't know and then
let alone the department having to try
to figure out how to enforce it so so it
is more important to they need that we
we figure out how to referee through
this and get through this and get this
done right so uh we definitely have time
so we can have another meeting and I
would urge the parties to get together
and have the department uh kind of help
these people through and it's and make
sure that if there are codes involved we
know which ones they are and and maybe a
bulletin would go out I guess to to make
sure that that there's enough people are
well informed and how this is supposed
to be done
okay
veto what
to talk about it
oh you want to just retain it
yeah you gotta put the mic in and uh
Chris nicolopolis insurance commissioner
and I'm excited about collaborative care
but a real collaborative care practice
has to be intentional it can't just be a
primary care practice or an emergency
room practice who happens to call a
referral for a psych
it is an intentional practice where we
bring in all the experts together to
care for the patient together there you
go and that should be happening with
your contract negotiation as part of
your individual contract negotiation
with the health carriers I was really
excited uh I think it was a few months
ago but my memory such it was probably
eight months ago Dartmouth Hitchcock
came in and they're rolling out this
program they're rolling out a true
collaborative care where they're and
it's not just for the emergency rooms
but it's for the total care so those
people are working together and that
they can build those calls between each
other because that's what we're talking
about here the individual meetings with
the patients are covered this is when
they call and say let me talk to you
about what's happening and I need you to
understand what we might have worked
through today
um I don't think we need this bill today
I think a collaborative care practice
that wants to entertain a contract with
a provider can do that we're hearing
that they want to do it and I believe
that we'll find out that in the long run
it's cheaper having all these people
work together rather than a bunch of
individual diagnosis
um if you're telling me that somebody
who's being brought into this
relationship isn't able to contract I
can make calls I'm happy to work with
the folks behind us on those things
um but I don't know that there's a
problem today
um I've been working Alex has been
primarily running this for the
Department
um
Mr Chicken so if I I want to be clear
about this you're informing us that
there are developments occurring
that are moving in the direction of
establishing collaborative care models
that would include the one that's in
Focus here in this bill
and those conversations are taking place
at a place such as Dartmouth Hitchcock
and with insurers to put this in place
and it's happening currently yes
thank you
yes representative Rose thank you when
you said I can make a call what did that
mean so if you if you told me that
outside of Dartmouth outside of a
contract with
um there were
uh Independence
I always get this wrong psychologists
who are being called in as a reference
to an emergency room
and they're not able to build that
they're told by their billing practice
don't bill so first I would look at what
is uh so I hear that and I think well we
probably want to incentivize
psychologists for taking those calls
from the emergency room doctor probably
um and there are a couple things I'd
want to look at one what's the contract
between the emergency room and the
provider because it may be in all kind
of all-encompassing contract it may not
be uh and whether or not that provider
is convinced Network the one that was
built it would be short-sighted to tell
those people who are making themselves
available for those emergency calls that
you can't be billing
I I know these folks's phone numbers and
I know their bosses numbers we find our
ways through that there are times where
I make those calls and they say Chris
that treatment they want to do isn't
medically necessary or isn't appropriate
okay you know that's right and there are
times where they say thank you we'll
bring it to our team and make sure we
modify our practices such that we're not
getting in the way of it so you don't
call Tony Soprano because I don't okay I
don't
um it's one you know one of the things
with in New Hampshire these regulated
entities we work pretty closely together
both the hospitals and in the agents and
the 5 000 consumers that call us each
year
um you know they don't they don't they
want to fix these problems and issues
and developments as the practice changes
in a way that's appropriate especially
when it saves the money
um and having a bill that my experts
can't tell me how we would enforce
the only comment I would make is you
made a suggestion about holding off one
week right well and I'm going to ask a
certain person whether he's
where we're at now well it seemed to me
that was a good idea because there is a
discrepancy here and maybe we ought to
get both sides to come up with the
details
before we make any decision as to what
we might do
right just pull it away I also had a
call for not doing it next week so so
John uh thank you
Chris
given that you just heard that the
insurance department is highly motivated
um is it passing legislation really
important to you or is it willing worth
waiting till September and hear what's
what's happened at that point and decide
whether we need legislation
I'm very excited I'm very excited to
hear the commission of statements
my client this is not my bill just to be
clear well you're like like I'm the
lobbyist my client has asked me to try
to push this bill through okay I can
certainly talk to my client fair enough
explain what happened today and come
back but I would still like to continue
the meetings with Point 32 and Anthem
around the potential for Amendment right
just to keep that moving forward okay
bless Mr chairman yeah you've already
told us that you're working on changes
as a result of what you are I mean so
this is we don't want to rush this and
then rush to do something that we don't
really need to do if it turns out that
this can get fixed without having to
have legislation passed so September
that you know we're all you know before
you know it'll be September that's why
I'm very glad you don't need to have
this out of committee until the 31st
right thank you okay thank you all right
so
we you okay
for a little bit of a delay here okay
all right so we will uh close the
subcommittee on a hearing on this bill
all right so Terry post telly
hello bro
uh
spear is replacing Vincent and
McAleer
is replacing Gibbs
and
Burrows
okay
did you tell Spear and Vincent not to
come in so that you could no I was going
to do this anyway okay
because I am a sponsor on this bill oh
yeah and because of respect
the senator Rosenwald
I spent hours investigating this
and I have some conclusions
that I think are very important before
this is my trade study but I don't want
to read that because it'll make
everybody crazy
ACA was put into law in 2010.
it got enacted upon in 2012.
insurance companies I mean states are
required to have implementations by
2014.
of the 18 states that have implemented
state-based Insurance estate-based
exchanges of the 18
17 of them did it for one reason and one
reason only and that was to expand
Health Care in their states
the outlier was Idaho they did it
for ideological reasons and I say that
kindly
they did it because they wanted to
isolate themselves from the federal
government flat out they had no
intention of doing anything about
insurance
anything past the minimum all right so
they're the outlier
and they have been in trouble with the
feds quite a few times over the years
and so they we can't include them in the
analysis
of the states that implemented it four
of them
New York Massachusetts California
and Maryland already had very extensive
plans in place had extensive medical
capabilities in place
and they understood their constituents
and they understood the problems as a
result of that they were very early
adopters because they were very early
adopters they were able to take care of
a lot of federal subsidies and because
they were able to start early and
because they knew what they had their
implementation was very straightforward
none of them did the implementations
themselves the actual nuts and bolts of
setting the software they hired people
but because they knew what they were
doing
they wrote specifications that were very
clear
and as a result of that that software
went very straightforward
the next Nine States
no I'm sorry the next
nine states right because I know it
doesn't count the next nine states did
not understand their problems and they
had three areas of problems
they had problems with not understanding
what their problems Healthcare problem
was they knew they wanted to get better
but they didn't know exactly what they
wanted to do mostly what they wanted to
do was subsidize the
um
premiums bring the premiums down and
subsidize insurance companies and plans
so they could get the uh deductibles
down
they didn't know how to get there and
they didn't know precisely how to reach
the information they needed and as a
result of that their requirements were
very poor
they didn't know how to get the output
they didn't have the input this is a
systems engineering problem flat out and
as a result of that they churned and
churned and churned and this software
was a mess and it took in some cases it
took five more years to straighten it
out
how many for that purpose nine people
nine states in that group and I can give
you a lot of details about what they
turned on
that was one problem they had the other
problem that they had was that the uh
they didn't pass the right laws you
can't have any success if your
brother-in-law is the one you hired to
manage the process which is what some
states did
what
the other problem that they had was as a
result of the failure of those first two
problems they now have political
problems
we don't have enough money we have too
much money we don't know what we're
doing nothing is working and it took
five years
in fact Rhode Island was kind of
impressive in the fact that they
actually get noted as the most improved
Health Care system or exchange system of
estate type they went from a ridiculous
five years
that they now have 3.5 percent uninsured
people
impressive and just so you know what the
comparison is Massachusetts who was an
early adopter uh has 2.5 percent
uninsured
Matt uh Maryland was the first adopter
they actually had a plan they actually
had an exchange up and running as a
prototype in 2011. way before anybody
else
so those are the problems that they had
and why they churned for five years and
why the software was very difficult
because they didn't have the
requirements and they didn't know their
inputs and they didn't know their
outputs
then we had the late adopters
in 2000 under the Trump Administration
as you know everybody knows they started
cutting back on Health Care they got rid
of uh tax Abate tax credits and a bunch
of other things that they did to try and
sabotage the plan and in fact they went
to the Supreme Court and they tried to
vote it out and we all know about the
McCain
savior of ACA
those States though by that time they
had the education to know how to
implement the plan so they went to a
state-based plan mostly to subsidized
premiums so they can get more people
insured because on the previous
administration they had lost so many
people
the states have done some very
Innovative things now over the over the
10 years they've done some very
Innovative things and I would have to
say
Kentucky's attitude and that's uh I
think pervasive among all of them
Kentucky's attitude is that Health Care
is a right not a privilege the States
owe it to these constituents to have
good health good quality Health Care
said it flat out but they've had a lot
of political issues but they're in very
and now as a result of this there are
software companies that can help you
convert over to a healthcare to a
state-based health care there's no doubt
about it
but the reason why that's not a turnkey
operation is they don't know what you
want to do they don't know what you want
New Hampshire has a problem their their
health care uh on uh what do you call it
uncovered health care is about six
percent not great
not not the worst I mean 18 for Texas is
the worst
with six percent not terrible but our
underinsured rate is pathetic it's 20
percent
are underinsured people who have to go
into debt so badly that they'll probably
lose their jobs lose their houses to pay
for the deductibles and the premiums
that they have to pay
we could probably do something in that
area
but the point of this is nobody
implements a state-based health care
because oh I think I'll Implement a
state-based health care
it's a means to an end it's like the
fourth step in the process the first
step of the process is to decide
if you have the will
all the resources to improve health care
and do you have a goal in mind without
that there's no point to doing it
because you're not going to save any
money
if all you're using it for is to
transition the health care from a
federal based Health Care to a
state-based health care it's not worth
the effort if that is all you want out
of it but if you want to get better
health care out there
subsidize the plans or do things like
what Washington State
Washington State implemented in 2019 a
public option it didn't work so well and
they're having a lot of problems but
they're not giving up the other thing
they implemented was health care for
undocumented immigrants
never going to get covered under the
federal plan
they churned on these they've worked
these kinds of Innovations this
collaborative care I saw one state that
they're pulling everything they've got
into that because they believe that's
going to get their drug problem down and
they believe they're going to get better
this year for the first time Colorado is
coming out with a public option plan and
their public option they say is going to
save both them and the federal
government 200 million dollars
because they can offer it at 23 percent
lower premiums and the state is an
effective Insurance Company
Washington had a lot of problems with
insurance companies being against it
whether Colorado succeeds or not that's
going to be something that everybody's
going to be looking at
and there are some states watching that
to see if that's going to work but if
we're not going to do something that's
Innovative if we're not going to try to
improve anything then we're the wrong
committee we're not the it's like as I
was using as an example if what you have
is a beautiful nail
and you're going to ask that nail
company to go design you a house I have
a nail I must I must want a house that's
crazy we're in the middle this this
doesn't belong with us this belongs to
the governor or it belongs
to the Health and Human Services
do they want to improve the health care
if they don't then we don't do this
and that's not our decision we're not in
that health care business
to design the health care itself that's
not what we do
so I'm afraid my suggestion would be not
do this and send it to the right
committee and ask the sponsors to
rewrite it
and aim it to find out do we want Better
Health Care other than that we don't do
this and that's my recommendation
doesn't belong here
so if there was a study committee the
study committee should really be people
who were
the goal is not about whether we want to
convert it but the goal is what can what
we New Hampshire should do to have
better health care
that's where it belongs that's where it
belongs and it needs and it needs the
governor to want to have have the will
to support that kind of an effort
because it's not a cheap effort because
states end up putting money in
into it is that all the states end up
spending more money but the cost of the
actual implementation of the base of the
state-based exchange is the smallest
part of it right but the argument was of
this bill is it's supposed to save us
it won't
because without the specifications
you're going to get garbage garbage in
garbage out it might not Mr chairman
because the question the point that
representative spear is making is it
will be dependent upon what kind of
Health Care exactly we want to provide
for people in New Hampshire right if we
design our own system it could be more
expensive it could be less expensive
ultimately what comes into play here is
the Constitutional issue
the federal government effectively
took this issue on and said this is a
national issue and we're going to oppose
the ACA upon all 50 states because we
can't tell the 50 states that they just
have to do this that's that that's
unconstitutional but they provided for
the states to be able to have their own
systems all right so it was kind of a
backdoor way to get states to to into
the program so either do it our way or
you can do it your way right and so
what's happening and through the
narrative that's been provided
To Us by representative Speer is that
there are a number of states that in
fact have decided to do that and some of
them have done it better than others for
a variety of reasons that she has
outlined so yes ultimately the question
here is whether there is the political
will
desire and will in New Hampshire to
design its own system which may or may
not cost more than the federal mandate
that's the question and is that really
is that really what we're asking this
study committee to do it's because she's
she's right this isn't just about money
this is about health care
and what we want to do as a state
so does this is that what's happening
being envisioned here through the study
committee it sounds to me representative
sphere in your analysis that that's not
clear to you it's not clear that this is
this this this study committee through
this
body
you only Implement based on history
based on the 18 States including Idaho
if you have a goal in mind this is the
state-based state-based exchange is a
means to an end it is one step in the
process
what's the goal you need to have a goal
and if you don't have a goal then you
don't move and there should be 50 goals
from 50 states and they're not going to
be the same because not every state
population is the same nor is its
political will the same
as to what it wants to do for its
population and please understand I
believe that we need better health care
I'm not stopping that what I'm saying is
we're not Commerce is not where you do
that so in terms of the duties in the
uh are you saying these are
these not good goals or these are I
think that the goals are okay as far as
they go but if they come through the
Commerce Committee the seriousness of it
and
the seriousness of it and the care that
will go into coming up with a solution
is not going to be there
it needs in all honesty if it wasn't
something said by the governor I don't
see why we would move ahead
I believe what representative spear is
telling at least about what I'm hearing
from her is that if you want to get your
cart if you want to get your if you have
a medical problem you don't go to an
auto repair shop
right so this is not she's saying this
is not the right committee this is not
where we ought to be doing this well
this order there's a better place
this is not necessarily this committee I
mean we could it you know it has right
now one member in the Senate and three
members of the house we could absolutely
say that those three members of the
house should be Health and Human
Services but if the governor isn't on
board
if it didn't come from the highest every
single state
every single state that did it came from
the will of the governor to improve it
as the Governor from Kentucky said
Health Care is a man is a right if they
don't have that will at the top
if they don't have the information that
says what has to be done then it's not
unless you want to take it on as an
academic exercise in which case I've
done some of the work and I can help you
not me
okay representative Burroughs yeah yeah
I mean even if you get three senators
and three
Representatives they're still not going
to have the expertise that's needed to
do it they're not the appropriate people
to do it so I don't think it matters
which committee it is it's I just think
yeah I mean we're smart but we're not
that smart so what is your
recommendation my recommendation
I hate to kill it
because I believe we need good health
care and I don't think our health care
is good this is not going to be the way
shall we retain it so that we can find
the right
incentives or should we just kill it
no don't just kill it I mean retain it
and maybe we can
talk to some people
you can find out where it should go and
I will put you in charge of subcommittee
to to
gather those people and help rewrite
this language to to inspire wait a
minute no I'm not saying that no no no
hold on I'll be glad to talk to the
people to anybody you think would might
be good right
but I don't know that we're going to
come out with another set of legislation
because you can't legislate from the
bottom so Mr chairman what I'm hearing
is if we're going to retain this at the
same time representative spear is is
making the case for executive leadership
right that is from from the governor
because what has to happen here is that
there has to be huge amounts of public
engagement to determine what the will of
the people are or is for health care for
its citizens we're not going to do that
through a study committee and we're not
going to do that through this committee
and and the role of the in our form of
government the role of the legislature
and I'm a legislator but the role of the
legislator is not the role of the
executive the role of the executive is
the one that's where the leadership has
to come from with the assistance of the
legislative branch in order to get
something as gargantuan as this to be
accomplished i i as somebody who's not a
huge fan of the ACA let me let me just
refer everybody back nevertheless to the
fact this did not come from the Congress
this initiative did not come from the
Congress this this came from the
executive branch of government and from
the president of the United States and
those that worked within the executive
branch collaboratively with the
legislative branch the Congress in order
to get this accomplished I can't imagine
that there would be an ACA today if
President Obama had opposed it to put it
negatively so that everybody gets the
point
we need Executive leadership now I don't
so a comment represented back later you
know if you if you look at ACA where did
that come from it came from Romney care
in Massachusetts yes that's where it
came from and so you had a governor that
was on board from the beginning and you
know we don't know if we did all of this
work and if Governor tsunu would veto it
so I don't know who would talk to the
governor about this but obviously it
would make sense to see make sure that
that he's on board the executive
committee is on board uh before anybody
proceeds on this I will say this in
looking at
what the states did to come up with a
successful plan
the research that went into
figuring out what was required what they
wanted to what they what the data was
even that's problematic for the state
that in order to even satisfy this study
committee to come up with what is
required and to come up with what are
our possible solutions could be
expensive enough that at the committee
level we could never do it
as a matter of fact on those four states
those four states that were immediately
successful they were subsidized by the
feds they didn't do that by themselves
one of the states said it cost them 85
million dollars to straighten out their
implementation just to get it to work 85
million dollars so before we start
talking about whether or not we're going
to start with a state-based we better
find out what
if there's any will
and therefore the resources because it's
not going to be cheap represent Phillip
with respect my colleagues before Romney
care was Romney care or Obamacare was
Obamacare it came from the bottom it
came from people wishing for these types
of programs to happen
and I think that if we we all know that
when our constituents want something to
happen our email boxes will tell us that
they want that to happen and the number
of emails that I've received on this
bill are zero which tells us that
there's not much of a public outcry for
a state-based Insurance Exchange
which makes this a bill in search of a
problem to would this bill be to reduce
insurance rates maybe would this be to
make a more user-friendly website maybe
would this to be expand insurance
coverage maybe but we don't know because
there's no public desire for this which
makes us the perfect Bill to see the
trash can
I wasn't going to say that
ouch
okay I'll make that motion
no okay Reverend collabro oh my God
any speed to legislate seconded by
all right any discussion on the itl
motion
no I I we appreciate what you did and do
the work on it well I appreciate the uh
the work that you've done absolutely
um and also your your uh your your
candor uh your analysis and your candor
is very much appreciated because I agree
we all want better health care for
everybody the question is how do we best
accomplish that yeah and to have such a
consensus on this committee is is is
truly refreshing and heartening thank
you
okay
uh uh Terry post purcelli hunt collabro
spear McAleer all those in favor of
inexpening to legislate please raise